all right Paul Chris stay with us please
I also want to bring in Ted Williams
former DC homicide detective Ted I know
you've been following all the details
authorities were
reportedly at card's home earlier today
so you you think they go to the home
that's cleared but they went back what
could have drawn them
back you know it could have been uh
quite a few things that could have drawn
them back and it may very well been a
phone pinion at that home that could
have led to them coming back there may
have also gotten information from
someone at the home who may very well be
trying to assist them but it is rather
strange because as we know uh it was
last night that this guy ditched his
automobile there and that was within
about a 13 mile radius of his home there
uh in Bowen and uh no one certainly
expected him to go back in that
direction there have been uh thoughts
about maybe he was going to be out on
his jet ski or he took a jet ski along
one of those riverways uh nobody knew
but I know that the Coast Guard
certainly was following up on that but
then as you remember earlier this
afternoon we heard the loud bangs
allegedly in the area of his residents
uh I would have to believe that the
authorities believe something uh and
that uh they know a great deal more of
course and I think Paul who's there with
you can tell you they do and Chris and
as a result of that they the information
that they have they may be trying to get
him out of that home if he's there they
believe and I'm sure they have it in a
sense set up in a barricade like Mana
all right gentlemen St hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else